Justin Bieber is single and definitely  not ready to mingle the pop star stopped  by Ellen Monday and dished on his love  life or lack thereof who are you dating  I'm not dating anybody you're not  looking so the 22 year old has been on  his purpose world tour for about a year  but explained that he doesn't use dating  apps to find love on the road when  you're on the road do you ever go on  tinder I don't know no dating app ever  know would you be curious to do that not  really you sound like you're really in a  good place like you're not really you  don't need to be dating right now just  about this very moment no yeah while the  sorry singer just wraps the European leg  of his world tour the travelling won't  let up anytime soon Justin announced he  will be launching a North American  stadium tour in August 2017  [Music]